Just north of here,
we have an example of what this could look like:
Silicon Valley.
A whole venture capital industry has grown up around the belief
that if people have good ideas and the desire to manifest them,
we should give them lots and lots and lots of money.
(Laughter)
Right? But where is our strategy for Theresa and Baakir?
There are no incubators for them,
no accelerators, no fellowships.
How are Jobana, Sintia and Bertha really all that different
from the Mark Zuckerbergs of the world?
Baakir has experience and a track record.
I'd put my money on him.
So, consider this an invitation to rethink a flawed strategy.
Let's grasp this opportunity
to let go of a tired, faulty narrative
and listen and look for true stories,
more beautifully complex stories,
about who marginalized people and families and communities are.
I'm going to take a minute to speak to my people.
We cannot wait
for somebody else to get it right.
Let us remember what we are capable of;
all that we have built with blood, sweat and dreams;
all the cogs that keep turning;
and the people kept afloat because of our backbreaking work.
Let us remember that we are magic.
If you need some inspiration to jog your memory,
read Octavia Butler's "Parable of the Sower."
Listen to Reverend King's "Letter from Birmingham Jail."
Listen to Suheir Hammad recite "First Writing Since,"
or Esperanza Spalding perform "Black Gold."
Set your gaze upon the art of Kehinde Wiley
or Favianna Rodriguez.
Look at the hands of your grandmother
or into the eyes of someone who loves you.
We are magic.
Individually, we don't have a lot of wealth and power,
but collectively, we are unstoppable.
And we spend a lot of our time and energy
organizing our power to demand change from systems that were not made for us.
Instead of trying to alter the fabric of existing ways,
let's weave and cut some fierce new cloth.
Let's use some of our substantial collective power
toward inventing and bringing to life
new ways of being that work for us.
Desmond Tutu talks about the concept of ubuntu,
in the context of South Africa's Truth and Reconciliation process
that they embarked on after apartheid.
He says it means,
"My humanity is caught up, is inextricably bound up, in yours;
we belong to a bundle of life."
A bundle of life.
The Truth and Reconciliation process
started by elevating the voices of the unheard.
If this country is going to live up to its promise of liberty and justice for all,
then we need to elevate the voices of our unheard,
of people like Jobana, Sintia and Bertha,
Theresa and Baakir.
We must leverage their solutions and their ideas.
We must listen to their true stories,
their more beautifully complex stories.
Thank you.
(Applause)